vous savez à ceux qui paient en totalité
leur carte de crédit à chaque mois ça
représenterait environ 60 % des
détenteurs
il ya les autres qui payent souvent en
partie leur solde ou seulement le
minimum requis mais sachez que ce
minimum va augmenter à partir du 1er ou
est-ce bon as mauvais pour les
consommateurs on en parle avec charles
tanguay porte parole de l'office de
protection du consommateur bonjour
monsieur tanguay bonjour on va regarder
tout d'abord monsieur tanguay voulu voir
un tableau d'ailleurs qu'on a préparé
les nouvelles mesures à partir du 1er ou
alors le paiement minimum mensuel sera
de 2 % du solde de la carte
il va augmenter ensuite annuellement de
2000 points de pourcentage jusqu'à 5%
donc après une période de six ans est le
minimum donc le paiement minimum devrait
déjà être fixé à 5 % du solde poli
nouveau contrat de quatre résidents
voilà exactement là pour les détenteurs
des cartes de crédit est ce qu'il s'agit
d'une bonne nouvelle mais j'ai taillé
bas nous croyons qu évidemment ça fait
partie des mesures adoptées en 2017 par
le gouvernement qui ont modifié la loi
sur la protection du consommateur donc
plusieurs de ces mesures là vont entrer
en vigueur le 1er ou dont celle qui fixe
un seuil pour le plus un seuil plancher
pour les paiements minimums en fonction
du solde
c'est nous sommes au québec la seule
province à réglementer cet aspect des
cartes de crédit parce que vous l'avez
dit c'est ça que ça peut coûter très
cher de ne payer que le minimum et sur
tous nos examens sanguins
lorsqu'on paye actuellement seulement le
seuil minimum combien de temps ça
pourrait prendre avant de rembourser 1 h
ben alors j'invite les téléspectateurs à
visiter notre page paiement minimum
intérêt maximum alors honneur on a mis
en place un simulateur
et si par exemple vous achetez un voyage
5000 $ de voyage sur une carte de crédit
qui est à 19 points 9 % des taux
d'intérêt ce qui est ce qui est le cas
de plusieurs cartes aller si vous faites
un paiement minimum de 2 % sur ce voyage
après combien ça va vous prendre 65 ans
alors
65 ans et vous aurez payer un frais
d'intérêts 22400 dollar et donc avec ce
même calculateur vous pouvez essayer
avec 4% de paiement minimum ce qui est
déjà à ce qu'ils disent mais ce qui est
quand même peu vous allez finalement
payer ce voyage en 13 ans au lieu de 65
est une offre vous aura coûté que 3400 $
de frais d'intérêt donc on voit que un
léger effort supplémentaire pour
rembourser sa carte de crédit peut avoir
des effets très apprécié à des économies
très importantes pour le consommateur
c'est un seul message
ça fait réfléchir elle veut réfléchir
assure eva est clairement on veut
s'attaquer donc à l'endettement est ce
que vous pensez que c'est une mesure qui
va permettre de diminuer donc de manière
importante la dette man ou une première
mesure maintenant cette mesure là parmi
plusieurs autres peuvent devraient
permettre de prévenir certains problèmes
d'endettement c'est certain évidemment
on qu'on connaît des des ménages qui ont
des soldes importants sur des cartes de
crédit certains ont plusieurs cartes de
crédit et plusieurs n'ont pas le choix
que de faire le paiement minimum et ils
restent pris dans une situation qui est
très coûteuse et souvent ils s'enlisent
dans cette situation donc on lance aussi
le message aux consommateurs que si vous
avez de la peine à faire le paiement
minimum c'est peut-être un signe qu'il
ya un problème d'endettement qui
voudraient chercher ils voudraient bien
il vaudrait mieux chercher de l'aide
auprès d'une association de
consommateurs notamment donne la
référence sur cette fameuse page de
notre site web
les associations de consommateurs offre
gratuitement des services de
consultation budgétaire dans les quatre
coins de la province
ce serait une bonne idée de les consuls
on voit d'ailleurs l'adresse le justin
bieber notamment l'accueil de l'office
de protection du consommateur et
seulement qu'on comprenne le ratio
d'endettement canada je crois le pôle
gagné trimestre 177 pour ça ça veut dire
que les canadiens doivent 1 dollars 77
et plus haut chaque dollar au champ
d'honneur disponibles alors lorsqu'on
parle d'endettement c'est quand même un
bon exemple
les détenteurs vous l'avez également
évoqué devront payer plus quel impact
sur les finances des ménages
donc comme je le disais ça se peut que
certains ménages aient de la difficulté
à absorber cette augmentation durant
bourse cette accélération du
remboursement mais à terme ils seront
gagnants donc et c'est pour ça que c'est
graduelle c'est pour ça qu'on annonce à
l'avance des hausses qui s'en viennent
du paiement minimum pour que les gens
puissent se préparer à cette réalité
commencé peut-être dès maintenant à
tenter d'accélérer le remboursement de
leurs cartes de crédit et un autre
mesure qui vise les prêteurs donc on
resserre plus généralement aussi le
crédit exactement il ya beaucoup de
mesure ça serait trop long mais vous
allez me réinviter paris beaucoup de
mesures entre autres les prêteurs
devront évaluer la capacité de
rembourser de l'an prometteur qui a des
mesures particulières qui visent qu on
appelle le crédit à coûts élevés donc
ses printemps qui prête a trait aux
coûts a trait aux taux d'intérêt et mais
qui devront désormais détenir un permis
et respecter des règles beaucoup plus
strictes à tête en terminant et
rapidement également monsieur tanguay
donnez nous du truc
donc pour nous les consommateurs
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire concrètement
le pro diminuer l'endettement alors il
ya évidemment votre adresse on peut se
rendre sur votre site il ya quelques
trucs dont on priorise les dettes dont
les coûts sont les plus importantes en
particulier souvent les cartes de crédit
mais chaque situation peut être très
spécifique alors il vaut mieux chercher
de l'aide ne pas avoir peur de chercher
de l'aide et de demander des conseils à
des experts quand on sent qu'on a des
véritables problèmes d'endettement
on n'arrive pas à joindre les deux bouts
ni à améliorer sa situation ça peut être
une bonne idée de consulter merci
beaucoup charles tanguay porte parole de
l'office de protection du consommateur
assurément qu'on va en reparler
merci ça m'a fait plaisir à voir